we know implicitly and because
Republicans have been caught admitting
this up more than once that low-income
and disproportionately non-white parts
of the country where it's expected that
voters will lean towards Democrats are
targeted for voter suppression this
includes particularly stringent voter ID
laws which are often defended his hey
it's a free ID which we now know isn't
really free because the documents you
need to get the free ID actually costs
money we know about limiting early
voting and limiting voting hours in
general we knew that this was hugely
racially tinged and we now have a new
study which has identified an additional
form of modern voter suppression that is
hugely racially tinged and that is long
voting lines the Joint Center for
political and economic studies looked at
data from the co-operative congressional
election study and what they wanted to
calculate was what's the average long
polling place wait time and then how
does that correlate to race I doubt most
people in our audience will be shocked
by this graph which shows us that black
voters have double the average wait time
of white voters and you will see that
blacks have the longest average wait
times at 23 minutes whereas whites have
the shortest average wait time as 12
minutes uh the ranking goes White's
Native Americans Asian Americans Latinos
and then African Americans of course
Native Americans having very very low
wait times because a significant portion
of their voting is happening in
particularly rural areas where they
actually have more of a say of how those
voting places are organized thus it is a
minority group that has not been
negatively affected by these Republican
tactics now why is this happening the
study points to two reasons number one
is lack of resources at polling places
in minority neighborhoods and we have a
bunch of studies on this there's one
from the Brennan Center which found that
three of the states with the longest
wait times Florida South Carolina and
Maryland saw voters of color
disproportionately going to polling
places with fewer machines and fewer
all workers we also see
disproportionately outdated voting
machines in the non-white areas we also
see more errors in the voting rolls one
in eight registration records is invalid
or has serious errors in some of these
areas so that's that's one explanation
the second one is cuts to early voting
programs non-white voters tend to take
advantage of early voting pro girly
voting initiatives at a higher rate than
white voters part of this is related to
economics part of this is related to
geography part of this is related to uh
other issues involving first been in the
south around black areas that are big
church goers it's related to churches
organizing to get voters to the polls
for early hours on a Sunday for example
two days before it's used a election so
we know we know that this is a factor
Florida reducing early voting days a
number of states reducing early voting
days so we looked at all the data i
looked at it closely this morning my
response I'm surprised that lines are
only twice as long on average for black
voters than for white voters I mean and
this is totally anecdotal but when I
voted in western Massachusetts I never
even waited one second I mean it was
basically all white people in the room
there were 50 voting booths or whatever
you call them and 15 people in there
people trickling in you never had to
wait even for a second now in Brooklyn
New York uh but much more significantly
non-white area I was never registered in
Brooklyn New York i kept my legal
residents in massachusetts when i lived
there but i walked by many times what
would have been my polling place on
Election days the line went out the door
people were frustrated many many non
white faces in those neighborhoods and i
would say how long have you been waiting
in people saying an hour an hour and a
half we don't know what's going on
reports of voting machines that were
outdated etcetera and here in Boston my
polling places in an area that basically
it straddles an area of low income
subsidized housing and sort of a more
gentrified area so it's pretty 5050 and
there were some pretty significant
delays there you had very few workers I
saw a huge line and two people checking
in
the entire location of voters as to how
do you have two workers here in western
Massachusetts we used to have six for an
area that was a fraction of the size uh
and so anecdotally we've seen this the
numbers make sense my surprise is that
black people are only waiting twice as
long to vote yeah it's as it's really
not surprising the tactics seem to have
paid off but uh yeah I guess it all
depends uh for many people just on where
you live population centers yeah uh
enthusiasm um and yeah but one thing the
Louis it's not just about urban areas
have more delays that sometimes what
people point to go say well just when
there's a lot of people in big cities
it's just going to take longer to vote
we're talking about averages here it's
still it's still racially tinged even
when you account for that for the type
of a precinct that you're looking at